many miles from either Maine or Idaho the potato
capitals of the country a firm in Wichita Kansas
makes capital out of potatoes this is the
Bartlett food products company formerly a
wholesaler of fruits and vegetables a few years
ago they started slicing up potatoes to make
potato chips and before long they were turning
out nothing but potato chips and related products
after the peel potatoes have been sliced they're
washed for the second time partly for cleanliness
but mostly to remove the starch in one continuous
operation excess water is blown off and the chips
are fried salted inspected and packaged all
automatically the same modern equipment and
techniques are used in the production of cheese
curls corn chips and the firm's other products
while fresh fruits and vegetables have been
forgotten this is another company that found
out what it could do best and concentrated on
that specialty to the benefit of all concerned
latest packaging methods ensure that the chips
will remain fresh and crisp indefinitely every
hour Bartlett converts to tons of potatoes into
one ton of chips sounds like an awful lot but
the way we Americans crunch away at them that's
only a fraction of national production when the
chips are down down on the table that is you
can be sure they won't stay there very long